in thinking about how we address some of
the the vex political and social
controversies of our time around race
around gender around sexuality and other
social identities I think that it's
important not to focus so much as a
recent issue of the New Republic
magazine does on the ways in which hate
drives social conflict but to look
behind the hate to see the role that
fear plays and it seems to me as someone
who lives in the society and also thinks
about the roots of social conflict that
the problem we face today is as much a
problem of fear as it is of hatred fear
specifically of difference we live in a
moment in history in which there's been
a proliferation and an acceleration in
difference all around us and if we in
the university in particular can come up
with ways to engage the broader society
around these issues of difference I
think we'll go some distance toward at
least talking in a different way than we
have in the past about how we can live
together with a cross and in a
productive and peaceful way with social
difference